IT IS A BIG BREAK AND A TRAGIC
OUTCOME IN THE CASE OF A MISSING
WOMAN IN TENNESSEE.
POLICE ARE JUST IDENTIFIED THE
BODY OF ELIZA FLETCHER, A SCHOOL
TEACHER AND MOTHER OF TWO
CHILDREN.
SHE WAS ABDUCTED WHILE JOGGING
EARLY FRIDAY AND NOW THE MAN
CHARGED WITH FIRST DEGREE MURDER
JUST WRAPPED HIS FIRST COURT
APPEARANCE.
GARY TUCHMAN IS LIVE AT THE
COURTHOUSE IN MEMPHIS WITH MORE
ON THIS.
WHAT'S THE VERY LATEST?
>> KATE, TEN MINUTES BEFORE THIS
ARRAIGNMENT WAS SCHEDULED FOR AN
ACCUSED KIDNAPPER, IT ULTIMATELY
BECAME AN ARRAIGNMENT FOR
ACCUSED MURDERER.
WE WERE INFORMED BY THE MEMPHIS
POLICE THAT THE BODY THAT WAS
RECOVERED LAST NIGHT WAS
IDENTIFIED AS ELIZA FLETCHER.
SUCH A SAD OUTCOME.
THIS WOMAN WHO WAS KIDNAPPED ON
FRIDAY HAD BEEN MISSING SINCE
THEN.
BEFORE HER BODY WAS FOUND, THE
ARRAIGNMENT WAS SCHEDULED IN THE
COURT FOR CLEOTHA ABSTON.
WE SAW HIM COMING IN.
HE WAS WEARING A MASK, HARD TO
TELL WHAT HIS FACIAL EXPRESSIONS
WERE BECAUSE OF THE MASK, BUT HE
LOOKED IMPASSIVE, HE LOOKED
IMPATIENT.
HE HAD HANDCUFFS BEHIND HIS
BACK.
THE ONLY THING HE SAID WAS YES
WHEN HE HAD TO SWEAR HE DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY FOR AN
ATTORNEY SO A PUBLIC DEFENDER
WAS GIVEN TO HIM.
HE WAS ARRAIGNED OFFICIALLY ON
THE KIDNAPPING CHARGES AND THEN
THE PROSECUTOR SAID YOUR HONOR,
WE WANT TO TELL YOU WE'RE ALSO
ADDING A FIRST DEGREE MURDER
CHARGE.
THE JUDGE SAID WE NEED TO HOLD
ANOTHER ARRAIGNMENT.
THAT WILL TAKE PLACE TOMORROW.
THE PROSECUTORS DON'T WANT HILL
TO HAVE BAIL.
HE HAS $500,000 BAIL RIGHT NOW
ON THE KIDNAPPING CHARGE.
THE PROSECUTORS WANT TO
COMPLETELY REVOKE IT.
THAT WILL BE HEARD TOMORROW.
EITHER WAY, A SAD AND TRAGIC
OUTCOME, AND THIS ACCUSED
MURDERER IS NO STRANGER TO JAIL
BARS.
IN THE YEAR 2000, HE WAS FOUND
GUILTY OF KIDNAPPING ANOTHER
PERSON, KIDNAPPING A MAN, A
LAWYER HERE IN MEMPHIS WHO
ESCAPED.
HE SERVED 20 YEARS BEHIND BARS.
HE GOT OUT OF PRISON IN NOVEMBER
OF 2020, A LITTLE LESS THAN TWO
YEARS AGO, AND NOW HE'S BACK IN
JAIL AGAIN AND HE WILL BE
AWAITING A TRIAL ULTIMATELY OR
PLEA BARGAINING PERHAPS SOME
DAY, BUT EITHER WAY, HE'S IN A
LOT OF TROUBLE BECAUSE HE'S NOW
ACCUSED OF FIRST DEGREE MURDER
OF THIS 34-YEAR-OLD MOTHER OF
TWO LITTLE CHILDREN, WIFE, AND
SCHOOL TEACHER.
VERY SAD STORY, KATE.
>> REALLY IS HORRIBLE.
GARY, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING THERE AND FOR YOUR
REPORTING ON THIS.
>>> LET'S GO TO TEESSEE RIGHT
NOW WHERE THE MEMPHIS POLICE
CHIEF IS SPEING AFTER THE BODY
WAS IDENTIFIED OF THE MISSG
TEACHER ILIZA FLETCHER.
>> IT WAS NOTHING LESS THAN
SYMPHONIC.
WE ARE ALSO VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE HUNDREDS OF TIPS THAT CAME
THROUGH OUR CRIMESTOPPERS AND
OTHER PLATFORMS FROM OUR
CITIZENS AT LARGE.
OUR ENGAGED AND SUPPORTIVE
COMMUNITY IS TRULY OUR MOST
VALUED ASSET.
JUST REMEMBER THAT THIS STILL IS
AN ONGOING INVESTIGATION.
AT THIS TIME, I WOULD LIKE TO
BRING UP FBI SPECIAL AGENT IN
CHARGE, DOUG CORNESKI.
>> GOOD MORNING.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, ON BEHALF OF
THE FBI, I WANT TO EXTEND THE
EXTREME SYMPATHY AND CONDOLENCES
OF OUR OFFICE TO THE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS OF ELIZA.
WHILE MOST OF US DID NOT KNOW
HER PRIOR TO THIS TRAGEDY,
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE RECENT
INVESTIGATION, WE GOT A SMALL
GLIMMER INTO THE LIGHT THAT SHE
WAS TO HER FAMILY AND FRIENDS
AND COMMUNITY.
NEXT, I WANT TO COMMEND THE
IMMENSE COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS OF
THE LOCAL, STATE, AND FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT DURING THIS
INVESTIGATION.
AS A FAMILY KNOWS, EVERY
POSSIBLE RESOURCE THAT WE HAD AS
A LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY TO
INCLUDE THE FBI WAS BROUGHT TO
BEAR TO BOTH FIND ELIZA AND HER
PERPETRATOR AND HOLD HIM
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND LAST, I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMUNITY FOR THEIR SUPPORT
DURING THIS INVESTIGATION, THE
MANY TIPS AND LEADS WE RECEIVED.
WE ARE A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMUNITY AS WELL.
AND THIS SITUATION, THIS TRAGEDY
IMPACTS US DEEPLY AS WELL.
SO WITH THAT, I WANT TO AGAIN
THANK THE COMMUNITY.
NEXT, I'LL BE FOLLOWED BY THE
ACTING ASSISTANT SPECIAL AGENTS
IN CHARGE, ALI ROBERTS FROM ATF.
>> FIRST, ON BEHALF OF ATF, I
WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS AFFECTED BY THIS
TRAGEDY.
NO RESOURCES WERE SPARED TO
LOCATE AND ARREST THE INDIVIDUAL
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
INCOMPREHENSIBLE VIOLENT CRIME.
ATF UTILIZED RESOURCES SUCH AS
ASSIGNING SPECIAL AGENTS, OUR
CANINE, AND USING THE E-TRACE
DATABASE AND OUR EXPERTISE AS WE
WORKED WITH STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERS TO BRING ABOUT JUSTICE
TO THE FAMILY AND FRIENDS IN
REFERENCE TO THIS TRAGEDY.
I WOULD LIKE TO BRING NEXT UP
U.S. MARSHAL TYRESE MILLER.
>> THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED STATES
MARSHAL SERVICE, WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO EXTEND OUR SINCERE
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY OF
ELIZA FLETCHER, HER FRIENDS AND
FAMILY AND THOSE THAT KNEW HER.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT, SHE TOUCHED
MANY LIVES, AND CERTAINLY A
LOSS.
AS I HAVE SAID ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS, THE MARSHAL SERVICE
HAS A VERY UNIQUE RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE MEMPHIS POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
AT ANY TIME THEY CALL, WE'RE
THERE TO ASSIST.
WE WERE GLAD TO RECEIVE THAT
CALL ON SATURDAY WHEN A SUSPECT
HAD BEEN IDENTIFIED.
WE THEN WENT ABOUT FINDING THE
SUSPECT VEHICLE IN QUESTION, AS
WELL AS THE SUSPECT HIMSELF.
HE WAS SPOTTED -- THE VEHICLE
WAS SPOTTED IN AN APARTMENT
COMPLEX, AND WE ALSO CONDUCTED
SURVEILLANCE ON HIM.
THEN WHEN HE TRIED TO MAKE A
MOVE, WE WENT IN AND MADE THE
ARREST SAFELY, AND TOOK HIM INTO
CUSTODY AND TURNED HIM OVER TO
THE CUSTODY OF THE MEMPHIS
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AFTER THAT, WE ALSO PARTICIPATED
IN THE SEARCH EFFORTS TO FIND
MS. FLETCHER, ALL DAY SUNDAY AND
ALL DAY MONDAY.
AND AS HAS BEEN STATED, IT WAS
NOT THE OUTCOME WE WERE LOOKING
FOR.
WE WERE DEDICATED AND COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING THOSE SEARCH
EFFORTS TO ASSIST OUR PARTNERS
UNTIL SHE WAS FOUND.
NEXT, I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
I ALSO WANT TO ADD MY
CONDOLENCES TO THE CONDOLENCES
OF MY OFFICE TO THE FAMILY OF
LIZA FLETCHER.
TO LOSE SOMEONE SO YOUNG AND SO
VITAL IS A TRAGEDY IN AND OF
ITSELF, BUT TO HAVE IT HAPPEN IN
THIS WAY WITH A SENSELESS ACT OF
VIOLENCE IS UNIMAGINABLE AND WE
EXPRESS OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES.
WE'RE PRAYING FOR THEM.
I'M PRAYING FOR LIZA AND PRAYING
FOR THE FAMILY.
WITH RESPECT TO THE FAMILY, BOTH
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OUR OFFICE
WAS IN CONTACT WITH THE FAMILY
THROUGHOUT THIS LONG WEEKEND.
THEY HAVE BEEN FULLY COOPERATIVE
THROUGHOUT THAT ENTIRE PROCESS
AND IN CONTRAST TO WHATEVER
BASELESS SPECULATION YOU MIGHT
HAVE SEEN, WE HAVE NO REASON TO
THINK THIS WAS ANYTHING OTHER
THAN AN ISOLATED ATTACK BY A
STRANGER.
WITH RESPECT TO THE FAMILY, WE
WERE IN TOUCH WITH THEM, AS I
SAID, THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF
THE WEEKEND.
I VISITED WITH THE FAMILY
PERSONALLY OVER THE WEEKEND.
I ALSO VISITED THEM THIS MORNING
WHEN WE HAD TERRIBLE NEWS TO
DELIVER TO THEM.
AND I HAVE A MESSAGE FROM THE
FAMILY THAT I WANT TO EXPRESS TO
ALL OF YOU.
THE PUBLIC, BUT ALSO THE MEDIA.
PLEASE RESPECT THEIR PRIVACY.
PLEASE ALLOW THEM TO GRIEVE.
AT AN APPROPRIATE TIME, THEY
WILL BE MAKING A STATEMENT, I
BELIEVE A WRITTEN STATEMENT WILL
BE FORTHCOMING, BUT WE REALLY DO
ASK THAT YOU AVOID INTRUSIVE
QUESTIONING AND RESPECT THEIR
PRIVACY.
I ALSO WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMEND ALL OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE PEOPLE
BEHIND ME AND ALL OF THE
AGENCIES THEY REPRESENT.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO
THE COMMAND CENTER OVER THE
COURSE OF THE WEEKEND.
I SAW WITH MY OWN EYES THE
SEAMLESS COOPERATION AMONG ALL
OF THEM.
CHIEF DAVIS REFERRED TO A MOMENT
AGO AS SYMPHONIC.
I THINK THAT'S ENTIRELY
APPROPRIATE ADJECTIVE.
I WATCHED MYSELF HOW THEY
COOPERATED AND I WAS VERY
IMPRESSED WITH THE SPEED WITH
WHICH THEY DEVELOPED LEADS, THE
SPEED WITH WHICH THEY TURNED
AROUND TEST RESULTS, THE
DILIGENCE WITH WHICH THEY
COORDINATED THE SEARCH EFFORTS.
THEY'RE ALL TO BE COMMENDED.
AS FOR OUR OFFICE, THE DEFENDANT
WAS ARRAIGNED THIS MORNING ON
CHARGES OF KIDNAPPING AND
TAMPERING WITH EVIDENCE.
HE'LL BE ARRAIGNED TOMORROW
MORNING ON NEW CHARGES WE NOW
HAVE TO BRING OF FIRST DEGREE
MURDER, PREMEDITATED MURDER,
MURDER IN THE COURSE OF
PERPETRATION OF A KIDNAPPING.
ANY KIND OF VIOLENCE, OF COURSE,
IS UNACCEPTABLE, BUT REPEAT
VIOLENT OFFENDERS PARTICULARLY
DESERVE A STRONG RESPONSE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'LL GET FROM
THIS DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO COOPERATE
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND WORK
CLOSELY WITH THEM AS WE ALREADY
HAVE.
SO THAT WE CAN DO OUR BEST TO
BRING JUSTICE TO THIS TRAGIC
SITUATION.
AND I'LL END THERE.
I'LL NOTE THAT BECAUSE THIS IS
STILL AN ONGOING INVESTIGATION
AND A PENDING CASE, AND I AS A
PROSECUTOR HAVE CERTAIN LEGAL
LIMITS ON WHAT I CAN SAY, THERE
ARE LIMITS TO WHAT KIND OF
QUESTIONS I CAN ANSWER OR CAN BE
ANSWERED BY ANYBODY, BUT I'LL
END THERE.
THANK YOU.
>> THIS QUESTION IS FOR ANYONE
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
DO YOU KNOW A MANNER OF DEATH,
A, AND B, WAS SHE KILLED IN THE
VEHICLE?
>> IT'S TOO EARLY FOR US TO
DETERMINE PLACE AND METHOD OF
DEATH AT THIS POINT.
>> CAN YOU DESCRIBE --
>> THE SUSPECT INITIALLY,
ACCORDING TO THE AFFIDAVIT, WAS
NOT BEING COOPERATIVE WITH
AUTHORITIES.
DID THE SUSPECT ULTIMATELY HELP
YOU FIND THIS VICTIM?
>> AT THIS TIME, I CAN'T
RESPOND.
WE'RE STILL WORKING WITH THAT
SUSPECT.
BUT AT THIS TIME, WE HAVE NOT
GOTTEN VERY MUCH INFORMATION
FROM THAT INDIVIDUAL.